I'm not attached to the gobs of
knickknacks and heirlooms I inherited
but what should I save that my children
might appreciate all of it Amy my big
storage unit and buy a bigger one right
so so the stat that is always staggering
to me there are five times the storage
units as a number of Starbucks in this
country and there are a lot of Starbucks
and so and by the way our houses are
twice as large as they were 50 60 years
ago and our garages are overflowing with
stuff so much so that we can't fit our
cars in our garages and still we have
the need for these storage lockers like
think so the United States I'm guessing
from that stat has by far the most
storage out of any other country in the
world I would think so I mean maybe
there's places like Dubai or something
but yeah but it I'm just thinking like
what how does that make us better or how
does that make us happier in fact maybe
great if it did the data would show that
it makes us depressed right I mean we
are I don't know how old this stat is
but I know you know five six years ago
the most depressed country in the world
was the United States and it's also one
of the richest countries in the world
yeah and there's something oh what's I
can't think of the term where you get
you know two graphs that are compared
there's something like there's there's
something that is signifying an inverse
relationship yes thank you yes there is
an inverse relationship I think between
between debt mmm-hmm
the things we have storage I don't know
I'm just that that's just my two cents
ma'am I want it could be way out I agree
with you and so before I get to my
really short answer here maybe the thing
is when you think about it just
practically like when's the last time
you got excited about a storage unit do
this every any storage unit I've ever
had in my life has been a burden yes
absolutely
that's a good that's a minimal maximum
there Shawn it's attributed to both of
us so my short answer is too few is
greater than two
much what I mean by that is sometimes we
have to deprive ourselves temporarily to
figure out what actually adds value to
our lives get rid of the access stuff
makes room for for what well for
experience but also for the things that
we're truly going to find value in and
by the way I think your kids future self
will likely appreciate if you let go so
they don't have to yeah you remember
that the event we had and like the the
couple was like man our parents getting
ready to pass away and we got all this
stuff to deal with him like it was
stressing them out so bad yeah and then
like the next people who had a comment
to say they were like you know like
right now we were holding on to all this
stuff for our kids and we're here to get
the leverage to like let go and like
seeing those two people stressing over
their parents stuff it was like a great
signifier for them on probably what
they're doing to their kids by holding
on to all that stuff yeah yeah yeah my
short answer would be when it comes to
saving precious heirlooms avoid the
guessing game by asking your kids what
they want now if your kids are one and
two years old and they can't answer it
well you can do one or two things like
you can just hold on everything and wait
until you know they will give you an
answer or you could just kind of start
paring down on this stuff right now I'm
not encouraging Amy here to just throw
away everything yeah but certainly she
could ask herself well I thought was a
kid yeah what if I if I was 15 what I
want to be burdened by all this stuff
mmm yeah yeah and by the way when they
turn 18 it's all their stuff they have
to take it with them yeah if he comes
their stuff and all of a sudden you
realize really quickly what stuff they
want to hold on to because it all
becomes just in case at that point
absolutely
you